Générique
...
-Bienvenue dans "Ces idées
qui gouvernent le monde".
Nous allons vous parler
de la sexualité des adolescents.
La sexualité ne se porte pas bien,
d'après les sondages d'opinion.
En témoignent les problèmes
qui s'en rapportent
et qui créent un véritable malaise
au point où certains observateurs
parlent de "sexualité toxique".
On pourrait presque dire
qu'il y a un désamour
pour les rapports sexuels
au sein des jeunes générations.
D'après les sondages portant
sur l'année 2022,
43 % des jeunes
âgés de 15 à 24 ans
n'auraient pas eu de rapport sexuel
dans les 12 derniers mois.
En comparaison,
les aînés en couples,
selon le même sondage
Harris Interactive de juillet 2023,
montrent que la révolution MeToo
n'a pas vraiment changé
les habitudes sexuelles,
avec des hommes plus entreprenants
et des femmes moins satisfaites
même si l'on observe
une hétérogénéité
des pratiques sexuelles
et de nouveaux modes de jouissance.
Quelles sont les raisons
de ce désamour
pour ce qui constitue,
quoi qu'on pense,
un penchant pour la vie ?
Et d'accuser, alors, pêle-mêle,
les abus de la société
de consommation,
où tout passe dans le commerce,
de la consommation pornographique
aux rêves.
La confusion entretenue
autour de l'orientation sexuelle,
quand elle est dogmatiquement genrée
par la radicalisation
des minorités agissantes
et une industrie numérique
des sexes,
ajoute au malaise.
Le besoin
de procréation-reproduction,
rendu insignifiant,
j'emprunte ce terme à Milan Kundera,
face au triomphe d'une espèce
de narcissisme érotomaniaque
qui se prend pour le nombril
de la modernité.
On peut aussi incriminer
dans ce malaise
les déliaisons sociales,
la déchéance du mariage,
les viols,
les féminicides.
Bref, un ressentiment
général à l'égard de l'amour
et du sexe
que nous allons interroger
avec mes invités,
que je vous présente.
Alain Vanier
est psychiatre,
psychanalyste,
et professeur émérite
des universités.
Bruno Falissard
est pédopsychiatre,
membre de l'Académie nationale
de médecine,
et également universitaire.
Giulia Sissa,
que nous avons en visioconférence,
est professeure d'université
à l'université de Los Angeles,
et également historienne
et philosophe.
Christine Vahdat...
Il prononce "va date".
Pardonnez-moi : Christine Vahdat,
Il prononce "va da".
gynécologue et obstétricienne.
Vous venez de voir la citation
de Simone Veil.
La baisse d'activité sexuelle
chez les nouvelles générations
vous inquiète-t-elle ?
Et à quoi l'attribuez-vous ?
Est-ce
une altération de l'altérité,
en écho à ce que
vous venez de voir,
avec la citation
de Simone Veil ?
Alain Vanier ?
-Alors,
c'est sûr qu'il y a
des modifications
de la vie sexuelle.
Est-ce qu'on est certain qu'il y a
une baisse de l'activité sexuelle ?
Je ne sais pas si des études,
comme ça...
Si on peut comparer
avec des études antérieures.
Ce qui est sûr,
c'est que la sexualité a pris
une place considérable
dans le discours social.
C'est vrai,
à tout point de vue.
Il hésite.
Mais est-ce que les pratiques
elles-mêmes ont beaucoup évolué ?
C'est une question que je me pose.
Voilà.
-Et vous, Bruno Falissard ?
Vous mettez en cause
ces sondages ?
-Non. Après, est-ce que plus,
c'est mieux, pour la sexualité ?
Je ne sais pas.
Je serais d'ailleurs
plus intéressé de savoir
si les adolescents
ou les jeunes adultes sont heureux
de leur sexualité,
quand bien même
elle ne serait pas fréquente.
Peut-être
que c'est nous qui avons consumérisé
la sexualité
avec le "plus, c'est mieux".
D'ailleurs,
compter un nombre
de rapports par mois,
est-ce pertinent ?
Est-ce que
faire l'amour une bonne fois
dans un mois,
en étant réalisé dans sa sexualité,
c'est pas mieux ?
Donc...
Après, je vous rejoins
dans votre introduction...
Je vois beaucoup de jeunes
avec de l'écoanxiété,
de l'éco-colère,
du fait que la Terre est
surpeuplée etc.
Et que se reproduire,
c'est pas forcément une bonne idée.
Et que la sexualité est en rapport
avec la reproduction.
Il y a peut-être une mise à l'écart
de la sexualité de ce côté-là.
Mais moi,
ça ne m'inquiète pas plus que ça.
-On va demander
à Giulia Sissa si c'est pareil
aux Etats-Unis.
Est-ce que vous diriez
que les jeunes ont moins
de relations sexuelles,
de rapports sexuels,
aux Etats-Unis ?
*-Eh bien...
Cette discussion a été lancée
en 2018,
justement, aux Etats-Unis,
par Kate Julian, dans un article
autour duquel, après,
s'est créée beaucoup de curiosité,
dans The Atlantic.
Et elle a lancé cette idée
de la "sex recession".
Et donc, j'ai regardé un petit peu,
j'ai vu qu'aussi, en Italie,
et en Europe,
ailleurs qu'en France,
il y a des statistiques
qui convergent
vers cette espèce de diminution
du "faire", n'est-ce pas,
et de la fréquence.
Alors Kate Julian,
c'est une essayiste,
et elle avait essayé de réfléchir,
justement, à des données,
à des statistiques,
et elle avait identifié
quelques points qui semblaient
s'imposer, des raisons
qui semblaient s'imposer.
La pornographie connaît...
-On va rentrer dans le détail.
-D'accord.
-Mais sur le...
Ils parlent en même temps.
-La réponse est oui.
Il y a une espèce
de convergence statistique
sur...
-Qui montrent ça ?
-Oui, absolument.
-Alors, on va avoir
le point de vue
français avec Christine Vahdat.
Vous confirmez cette chose-là,
Christine Vahdat ?
*-Non. Moi, d'abord,
c'est un peu biaisé puisque je vois
des adolescentes, par mon activité
de gynéco-obstétricienne.
Et ces adolescentes que je vois,
il ne m'apparaît pas,
en 35 ans d'exercice,
qu'il y ait une baisse
de la fréquence
des rapports sexuels.
Par contre,
ce qui me marque,
c'est une augmentation
d'un ressenti de crainte,
de la part de ces adolescentes,
sur comment vivre leur sexualité.
Sur le problème du consentement,
sur la peur...
consécutive de la pornographie,
on en a parlé,
mais aussi de se retrouver
sur des réseaux sociaux,
parce qu'elles ont eu
des actes sexuels avec des garçons
donc il y a une perte de confiance
qui me paraît beaucoup plus
importante.
Mais sur la diminution
de la fréquence,
je ne le note pas du tout
dans mon exercice.
-En somme,
vous n'êtes pas d'accord
avec ce sondage.
Peut-être que ce sondage
est erroné,
mais je voudrais quand même
vous faire préciser cette question :
l'orientation sexuelle,
aujourd'hui,
reste biologiquement stable
entre hommes et femmes,
pour la majorité de la population.
Sociologiquement,
c'est autre chose.
On a une sexualité polymorphe,
y a les théories du genre,
il y a l'abstinence,
l'asexualité
l'hétérosexualité,
l'homosexualité.
A votre avis,
et ça va préciser votre propos,
est-ce qu'on ne cherche pas
à promouvoir une alternative
à la sexualité
à travers la dégénitalisation
des rapports sexuels ?
Autrement dit,
des rapports sexuels
sans pénétration,
sans accouplement, etc.
Oui, Bruno Falissard ?
-Oui, mais d'abord,
je crois que c'est propre
à l'être humain
de séparer
ce qui est de la libido,
du génital et du sexuel.
Notre sexualité,
ça n'est pas que du génital.
S'embrasser sur la bouche,
c'est pas génital
mais ça fait partie
de la sexualité.
Et il y a de la créativité
chez les humains
pour faire exploser le sexuel
en tout un tas de facettes
et pour le meilleur, d'ailleurs,
en général. Donc moi,
c'est pas une inquiétude.
C'est une transformation sociale
qui est comme elle est.
-Ca vous inquiète,
Alain Vanier ?
-Ce qui change aussi,
je vais tout à fait
dans le sens
de ce que dit Bruno,
ce qui change beaucoup aussi,
c'est l'espèce de transparence
des pratiques
et de la vie sexuelle.
On avait une vision
moins évidente
de tout ce qui se passait
dans le secret
de la vie sexuelle qui,
aujourd'hui,
est quand même exposée,
spectacularisée, etc.
Il me semble qu'il y a là
une modification
tout à fait importante.
De plus, je crois qu'il y a
un élément, peut-être,
qu'il faudrait ajouter,
c'est aussi
une pente à l'isolement,
une pente à la solitude,
dans le monde d'aujourd'hui.
A tel point qu'il y a même,
dans certains pays, un ministère
ou un secrétariat d'Etat
à la Solitude,
qui me paraît
une question
très, très importante.
-Alors,
Dr Christine Vahdat,
vous qui êtes gynécologue,
est-ce que
cette dégénitalisation
de la sexualité,
vos patientes en parlent ?
En quelque sorte,
est-ce qu'elles cherchent
une sexualité alternative
à une sexualité qui serait,
disons,
uniquement basée
sur les rapports sexuels.
Christine Vahdat ?
*-Alors,
j'ai quand même...
Sans vouloir caricaturer,
j'ai une grande majorité
de patientes
qui n'ont rien changé
dans leurs habitudes
avec la crainte
dont je vous parlais
qui bloque quand même les...
Aller vers l'autre.
Il y a la problématique
de la confiance
et du consentement
qui pose problème
dans les relations
entre les adolescents.
En tout cas, c'est ce que
me relatent les patientes.
Ensuite, il n'y a pas de recherche
de différence.
Et après, j'ai une minorité
de patientes
qui vont se dire non-binaires,
qui vont remettre en question
leur genre,
et on pourra parler de ces demandes
de parcours de transition.
Et, dans celles
qui ne veulent
absolument pas d'un genre binaire,
il va y avoir effectivement
une absence totale de désir sexuel,
d'érotisation
de la relation à deux,
et des comportements
qui seront différents
mais ça reste une minorité.
-Dr Vahdat,
est-ce que c'est différent
pour les femmes
que vous avez comme patientes,
qui ont 20 ans,
et celles qui ont 50 ans ?
Pareil pour les hommes,
mais vous êtes
gynécologue...
-Je ne vois pas d'homme
donc je vais parler des femmes.
C'est pas du tout pareil que...
pour les patientes
de 20 et de 50 ans,
mais mes patientes de 50 ans
que j'ai vues
quand elles avaient 20 ans,
puisque ça fait plus de 30 ans
que je suis installée,
elles avaient la même...
la même préoccupation.
Il y avait simplement
une expression moins grande.
Je rejoins un des intervenants
de tout à l'heure.
Effectivement, il y a
une libéralisation de la parole.
Peut-être que certaines patientes
qui n'ont pas
de relations sexuelles à 50 ans,
ou qui n'en ont jamais eu, qui...
à 20 ans ne s'affirmaient pas
comme étant
non dans un modèle binaire
ou refusant toute forme
de sexualité.
Donc je retrouve des patientes
qui n'ont peut-être pas exprimé
ce que, maintenant,
à 20 ans,
elles pourraient exprimer,
ou que, pour celles
qui ont 20 ans,
elles peuvent exprimer facilement.
Je sais pas si je suis claire
dans mes explications...
-Oui, on vous a comprise.
Je voulais demander l'avis
de Giulia Sissa. A ce niveau,
vous savez qu'on dit
traditionnellement en France
que tout ce qui concerne
la modernité,
à la fois dans ses progrès
comme dans sa perversité,
ça nous vient des Etats-Unis.
Est-ce que,
finalement,
cette dégénitalisation du sexe,
ça vient des Etats-Unis ?
-Eh bien, si je reprends le fil,
justement, de cette enquête,
qui a enclenché la conversation,
dans laquelle nous sommes engagés
aujourd'hui, ce qui émergeait,
justement,
de ces données, c'était...
la masturbation,
c'est-à-dire l'auto-érotisme
comme une forme de sexualité,
de sensualité,
et je pense que la sensualité,
c'est bien,
connectée à la présence, donc,
massive et tellement facile,
tellement accessible, des images
pornographiques.
Deuxième point, ce qui vient
des Etats-Unis semble être
qu'il y a moins de relations stables
parmi les jeunes,
parmi les adolescents,
et donc moins de...
Comment dire ?
De fréquence dans la sensualité
et dans la sexualité.
Et puis,
les pratiques de rendez-vous
sur Tinder et autres sites,
où il y a beaucoup
de "hooking up"
beaucoup de rencontres
mais pas nécessairement
de rendez-vous
et de pratiques sexuelles
qui suivent.
Et puis, et ça concerne apparemment
les jeunes femmes, et j'ai trouvé ça
très intéressant, c'est que,
justement, apparemment,
- je dis "apparemment"
parce que je ne suis pas
la chercheuse qui a travaillé
sur ces données -
la pornographie favorise
une espèce d'art d'aimer,
n'est-ce pas,
de technique du rapport sexuel,
de la posture,
du "faire" sexuel...
-On vous a entendue.
-...qui est douloureux
pour les femmes.
-On vous a entendue.
Vous voulez intervenir,
madame Vahdat ?
-Oui...
-Et je termine.
L'autre point,
qui est très important, je pense,
et ça recoupe
ce que je viens d'entendre,
justement,
d'un point de vue
des pratiques gynécologiques,
c'est le fait
que les jeunes femmes,
mais pas nécessairement
seulement les femmes,
sont moins à l'aise
dans leur corps.
Et ça, c'est...
Tout ça interroge.
C'est-à-dire...
-On vous a entendue.
On vous a entendue,
Giulia Sissa.
Je voudrais avoir l'avis,
sur ce point,
du docteur Vahdat.
-Je voulais dire
que pour les 14-20 ans,
dans mon expérience,
je n'ai absolument pas
la notion de Tinder, etc.
Les rencontres se font
comme autrefois,
au lycée,
dans des groupes d'élèves...
ou les copains
du frère, etc.
Je m'appuie pour dire ça
sur une enquête d'Isabelle Clair,
qui a été publiée
en mars 2023.
C'est une sociologue,
Isabelle Clair.
Elle a publié ça...
Donc, c'est très récent.
C'est une enquête menée sur 20 ans
dans des groupes sociaux
totalement différents.
C'est une étude française
qui démontre, contrairement
à ce qu'on pourrait entendre
sur les chiffres précédents
et caetera
que, vraiment,
le couple hétérosexuel
reste l'horizon rêvé
des adolescents.
C'est vraiment
ce vers quoi
tendent les adolescents
pour une grande majorité
d'entre eux.
Le modèle
au coeur des préoccupations,
c'est vraiment être en couple
dans une relation hétérosexuelle.
C'est après
que d'autres formes,
des modèles,
des désirs,
même des sexualités
différentes apparaissent.
Le démarrage 14-20 ans,
c'est un modèle
très hétérosexuel
et très correspondant aux critères
que l'on connaît
depuis des années.
-Philippe Brenot,
vous êtes psychiatre,
anthropologue, sexologue.
Vous venez de nous rejoindre
dans cette discussion
à laquelle
vous allez participer.
Le docteur Vahdat
a cité une étude
d'Isabelle Clair,
en disant que chez les adolescents,
le modèle hétérosexuel restait
un modèle.
Mais, dans cette étude,
elle parle également,
je parle d'Isabelle Clair,
des diverses formes
de faire l'amour,
selon l'espace social,
le lieu de résidence, la religion...
Est-ce que c'est évident,
Bruno Falissard ?
Vous pouvez nous dire
quelques mots là-dessus ?
-Oui, l'exercice
de la sexualité
est culturellement dépendant,
et ça depuis la nuit des temps.
Euh... Oui.
Comme en ce moment,
en plus,
les représentations culturelles
changent à toute vitesse,
car nous sommes exposés
à des différences
via les réseaux sociaux,
les jeunes sont confrontés
à une multitude de plaisirs,
un vertige de l'infini sexuel
dans lequel il faut piocher,
éventuellement en changeant
le genre, etc.
Il y a sûrement
un temps d'adaptation à avoir.
C'est vrai qu'on peut ressentir
un malaise auprès des adolescents,
tellement ça change vite.
"Le mal de l'infini",
comme disaient les sociologues.
Etant un optimiste invétéré,
j'imagine que,
dans quelques années,
nous arriverons à digérer tout ça,
et que finalement,
on arrivera à trouver
sa place
dans sa sexualité.
-Philippe Brenot,
vous croyez
qu'il y a
un invariant sexuel
ou un sexuel
qui se meut complètement,
qui se transforme
en permanence ?
-Les invariants sexuels,
il y en a très peu.
Mais pour dire une chose,
je rappellerais
que la sexualité humaine,
elle est
comportementalement apprise.
C'est-à-dire
que tout est appris,
et ça,
on ne le dit pas suffisamment.
Ca va être appris
au fil des expériences successives.
Elle est
comportementalement
apprise
et socialement construite.
Elle se construit en fonction
des images que l'on voit.
Il est évident qu'un enfant,
aujourd'hui, dans notre société,
vous venez de le dire,
qui bouge
à chaque moment...
C'est pas les mêmes
en 2000, en 2010,
en 2015,
avec les hashtags
qui ont tout changé,
et aujourd'hui.
Dans un pays très restrictif,
en Iran, un enfant
n'a pas les mêmes repères du tout.
Il aura sa sexualité
qui sera pas la même.
La grande difficulté,
c'est qu'en même temps
que ces repères évoluent...
Et aujourd'hui,
on va y revenir,
car c'est ça
qui pose problème.
Les repères d'orientation
et d'identité,
en même temps qu'ils évoluent,
il faut pas oublier
que la sexualité
se construit.
C'est-à-dire
que plus on cumule
des expériences...
C'est en fonction
des expériences vécues
qu'on aura
sa propre sexualité.
Toutes les sexualités
sont personnelles.
-Ici, sur ce plateau
de LCP,
nous avons eu
un grand économiste,
Daniel Cohen,
qui est aujourd'hui décédé
et qui expliquait magistralement
que les relations sociales
étaient ébréchées,
pour ne pas dire plus,
par le numérique.
J'aimerais avoir
l'avis de Giulia Sissa
sur ce point.
Est-ce que vous pensez
que le numérique porte atteinte
à la sensualité,
à la sexualité,
à l'amour, et caetera ?
Essayer de parler sans...
Comment dire, sans tabou,
parce que dès qu'on parle de ça...
-Sans tabou.
Ni totem, ni tabou,
c'est-à-dire que...
Je n'ai pas peur
du numérique.
Je ne le fréquente pas
nécessairement,
mais ça ne me fait pas peur.
Je pense que la ruse
de la raison
fait qu'on trouve
des manières toujours plus fines,
plus malignes,
plus intelligentes
de faire avec
les technologies qui sont
à notre disposition.
Je ne sais pas si c'est ça,
le sans tabou.
Oui...
Je parlais avec des amis
qui disaient...
C'est un couple d'hommes
qui sont mariés
et qui s'adorent.
Ils disaient :
"Quand nous parlons
à des gens plus jeunes,
"nous racontons comment
nous nous sommes rencontrés.
"Nous nous sommes rencontrés à Rome
dans un café.
"Ils sont
tout à fait surpris,
"parce que justement,
les pratiques de la rencontre
"se sont transférées
sur Internet."
Est-ce qu'il faut
regretter ça ?
Est-ce qu'il faut dire qu'on a perdu
ce qu'on appelle le romantisme,
qu'on a perdu cette dimension
de l'art d'aimer
et de la civilité érotique,
de la séduction intéressante ?
Moi, je dis pas nécessairement.
Pas nécessairement.
Peut-être qu'il y a
dans ces manières de faire
une temporalité différente
de la séduction,
une façon d'attendre,
de cultiver, précisément,
la recherche, la quête
du désir de l'autre,
qui n'est pas plus mal.
Pourquoi il faudrait se précipiter
au lit tout de suite ?
Je suis une féministe
de la deuxième vague,
j'ai vécu les années 70,
"sous les pavés, la plage",
et la plage était une plage
où on faisait surtout l'amour.
Mais, est-ce que c'était bien ?
Est-ce que cette espèce
de glissement évident
de la conversation
à l'acte sexuel
était agréable à chaque fois ?
Je ne sais pas.
Je ne suis pas sûre.
-Oui.
Donc, peut-être que c'est
une bonne nouvelle
que les jeunes
prennent le temps,
peut-être de se faire moins hâtifs.
-Merci, Giulia Sissa.
Alors, Alain Vanier,
dans votre consultation,
eu égard au Covid
et au numérique,
est-ce que vous pensez
qu'on peut faire l'amour
avec un ordinateur ?
-Ah...
Dans ma consultation,
c'est sûr que...
Parce que ça prolonge
ce qu'on se disait tout à l'heure.
C'est sûr
que les pratiques solitaires
devant la pornographie
ou devant l'ordinateur,
ou même avec un autre
à travers l'ordinateur,
se sont beaucoup développées.
Il faut quand même dire
que ce que nous vivons,
c'est une sorte de troisième
révolution industrielle,
la révolution numérique.
Elle aura des effets
sur le lien social,
inévitablement.
Maintenant, qu'il y ait
une sexualité...
normale...
comment dire, orthodoxe, etc.
Ca, je pense
que c'est une fantaisie
qui a appartenu
aux ordres religieux divers.
La sexualité humaine,
comme disait Freud,
est fondamentalement dénaturée,
donc elle n'a pas
d'orientation spécifique,
une fin spécifique
qui irait de soi.
-Et pour vous,
Philippe Brenot,
l'influence du numérique sur...
-L'influence du numérique
est évidente.
Le numérique, et surtout Internet,
ça date en gros des années 2000.
Avant, ça existe
un petit peu.
Depuis,
tout a été transformé.
Et, ce qui vient d'être évoqué
lors des interventions
d'Alain Vanier
et de madame Giulia,
dont je n'ai pas le nom complet...
-Sissa.
-...marque bien
la dimension du temps
qu'il faudrait avoir.
Je crois qu'on est
dans des sociétés,
aujourd'hui,
où il n'y a pas de recul,
et on le voit avec le wokisme :
il faut réagir
dans l'émotion,
dans l'immédiateté.
Or, et on va reculer
de 30 ou 40 ans
en arrière,
je crois que la société
laissait plus de temps
aux débuts de la sexualité
et qu'il y avait peut-être
un temps de la maturation,
de la maturation psychologique,
relationnelle.
Est-ce que les gamins
qui sont confrontés très vite
à un sexe qu'il faut assumer,
avec des impératifs,
orgasmiques, tout ce qu'on veut,
est-ce qu'ils sont matures
au niveau de la relation ?
Il vaudrait mieux être mature
au niveau de la relation
et de soi-même...
Je pense
qu'avec le numérique,
ça s'est accéléré,
et ça, c'est un handicap,
mais on est obligés de faire avec.
-Alors, d'après le sondage
Harris Interactive,
sur lequel vous n'êtes pas d'accord
pour la plupart,
en considérant qu'il y avait moins
de relations sexuelles
dans les jeunes générations,
il y a également,
dans ce même sondage,
une analyse des effets
de la révolution MeToo.
Ces effets se font attendre.
Autrement dit,
dans le domaine
des relations sexuelles,
MeToo n'a pas changé
grand-chose.
Qu'en pensez-vous,
docteur Vahdat ?
-Alors oui,
ça rejoint tout ce que je lis
et toutes les études...
Là, je suis
tout à fait d'accord là-dessus.
Il y a pas de modification
significative dans le comportement.
Alors là,
j'étends mes propos
à mes patientes
au-delà de 20 ans,
qui ne sont pas
que des adolescentes.
On retrouve les stéréotypes
que l'on connaissait.
Je voudrais juste revenir,
même si c'est pas le propos,
sur des chiffres
qui me paraissent
extrêmement inquiétants,
qui sont ceux...
70 % de garçons sont allés
sur des sites pornographiques,
et 40 % des filles.
Je dis ça pour rebondir
sur ce qui a été dit
par le dernier intervenant,
et je pense
que c'est très important,
parce qu'effectivement,
il n'y a pas la maturité.
Je le ressens
dans mes consultations.
Pardon de m'éloigner
de votre question,
mais je voulais insister dessus.
Je pense que c'est
ce qui fait aussi l'appréhension,
dans mes jeunes patientes
au-delà de 14 ans,
sur ces premières
relations sexuelles.
Il y a une espèce de modèle
qui leur a été imposé,
de modèle qui correspond pas
et qui ne fonctionne pas
avec l'amour,
avec les sentiments,
qui est imposé
par ces images pornographiques,
et je pense que c'est vraiment
le problème essentiel.
Toujours pour revenir
sur la sociologue
dont j'aime beaucoup l'étude,
je pense que...
ça va en plus être différent
en fonction de la relation
qu'elles ont avec leurs parents.
Dans des familles structurantes,
qui tiennent la route,
ces images pornographiques
n'auront pas
le même retentissement négatif.
Pardon d'être repartie
un peu en arrière.
Sur MeToo,
j'ai juste à dire
qu'il n'y a pas de modification,
pour moi,
dans les habitudes sexuelles
de mes patientes en tout cas,
depuis la révolution MeToo.
-Alors, Bruno Falissard,
moi, j'entends ce que disent
des médecins,
gynécologues, psychiatres, etc.
On a le sentiment
qu'il y a un décalage
entre les expériences vécues,
telles qu'elles sont ressenties,
et les études
qui viennent schématiser
la chose.
Autrement dit, la sexualité,
c'est quelque chose...
Freud disait
que c'était dur,
mais c'est dur
d'en parler...
d'exprimer ça
avec une transparence
du langage ?
-D'abord, sommes-nous transparents
au sujet de notre propre sexualité ?
J'en suis pas sûr.
Est-on capable d'en parler
de façon objective ?
Pas sûr non plus.
Ca a été dit
tout à l'heure,
la vraie question de MeToo,
c'est celle du consentement.
Avec les jeunes
avec lesquels je suis,
cette question
est vraiment compliquée,
même au plan philosophique.
Qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
de consentir à quelque chose ?
Qui est
le "je" qui consent ?
Puisque quelque part,
j'en ai envie,
mais j'en ai pas envie.
L'autre a envie de moi,
son désir provoque mon propre désir,
mais est-ce que c'est
mon désir à moi,
alors que c'est le sien ?
-Les femmes disent
que céder
n'est pas consentir.
-Oui, mais tout ça
est terriblement compliqué,
et je pense que...
c'est très bien aujourd'hui
de poser la question
du consentement,
c'est un progrès manifeste,
mais ne pas dire
que cette question
est insoluble, philosophiquement,
c'est dramatique.
Chacun doit se dire
à l'intérieur du couple :
"Quand tu me demandes ça,
"est-ce que je consens ?
Parlons-en."
Mais il y a pas de vérité là-dedans.
-Sur MeToo,
Alain Vanier, le fait
que ça n'ait pas changé...
Dans l'étude,
on dit que les femmes
restent plutôt soumises
à la puissance machiste.
Est-ce que c'est...
-Alors...
-C'est intéressant de voir
que les évolutions sociologiques
ne se traduisent pas,
en quelque sorte,
sur les pratiques elles-mêmes.
-Je crois qu'il y a deux choses.
Déjà, je rejoins
ce que dit Bruno très justement,
c'est très compliqué,
la question du consentement,
parce que je donne à l'autre...
Je pense...
Combien de patientes
m'ont expliqué
que le rythme de leur désir
ou de leur envie
n'était pas du tout le même
que celui de leur compagnon,
par exemple,
ou de leur compagne, même,
dans des cas
de couples homosexuels,
mais qu'en même temps, par moments,
pour pas avoir d'histoires
ou pour que la relation
soit bonne, on cède.
Dans ce cas, est-ce que
c'est un consentement ?
Un don qu'on fait à l'autre ?
C'est compliqué.
Sur les effets de MeToo,
il me semble qu'il va falloir...
Ce genre de choses a des effets,
mais à mon avis,
il faut du temps.
Entre le moment où il y a ce...
Comment dire ?
Cette venue à jour,
cette exposition enfin
de toutes ces...
complications
dans les relations hommes-femmes,
il me semble qu'il faut
plus d'une génération
ou plus de quelques années
pour pouvoir en mesurer les effets
dans la vie subjective,
parce que ce qui est
compliqué,
c'est que toutes ces images,
tout ce qui sort
dans les discours,
tout cela est vécu aussi
comme des impératifs,
comme des modèles,
en particulier dans la culture
dans laquelle nous sommes.
Donc il faut beaucoup de temps
pour que tout ça prenne place
dans les liens sociaux,
sans compter qu'à mon avis,
on est dans un moment social
où il y a une sorte, véritablement,
d'émiettement.
Ce qui va conduire
ou organiser
certains groupes
n'est pas ce qui conduira
d'autres groupes.
-Giulia Sissa,
vous m'entendez ?
Aux Etats-Unis,
encore une fois,
on revient
sur les Etats-Unis,
on considère
qu'un regard...
suscitant un désir sexuel
est déjà prédateur.
Est-ce que vous pensez
que cette chose-là,
c'est pas ce qui a affaibli
le mouvement féministe ?
Et quand on prend la France,
vous avez vu la citation
de Florence Foresti,
mais de grandes voix,
que ce soit
Catherine Deneuve,
Sylviane Agacinski
que ce soit
Mme Elisabeth Badinter,
ont considéré
que cet excès-là
a nui à la révolution MeToo.
-Vastes questions, au pluriel.
J'ai envie de commencer
en disant que...
c'est une question de situation,
c'est-à-dire que MeToo a ciblé,
dans le témoignage de ces femmes
qui disent "moi aussi",
des relations
qui deviennent érotiques
au mauvais moment
et quand ce n'est pas vraiment
la raison pour laquelle
une femme s'engage
dans une relation,
dans une conversation
avec un homme.
Donc l'idée,
c'était que c'est lié
à une espèce d'erreur,
encore une fois,
de situation.
Je suis là
dans un entretien professionnel,
je suis là dans un colloque,
je suis là dans une relation
qui est une relation
de subordination
par rapport à un patron...
-Vous estimez
que si on dit de vous
"vous êtes belle",
c'est une relation
de subordination ?
-Non, je dis pas ça.
Je dis justement
que tout dépend
du quand et du où
et du moment situationnel
dans lequel on me dit
que je suis belle.
Je peux même être offensée
si on ne me dit pas
que je suis belle
dans une situation
où il y a une intimité
même ironique, esthétique,
érotique avec quelqu'un,
et tout le monde a ce désir
d'être désiré,
mais c'est le moment qui compte.
Le mouvement MeToo
a mis en évidence, justement,
cette espèce de ras-le-bol
des femmes
d'être traitées
dans le registre érotique
au moment
où elles n'en ont pas envie.
-Giulia Sissa,
est-ce qu'il n'y a pas
une contradiction
entre ce que vous dites...
D'un côté, vous dites
qu'on peut dire certaines choses
dans une intimité,
et d'un autre côté,
accepter la médiatisation complète
de la sexualité,
en considérant
qu'elle doit suivre la modernité.
-Oui. Je dis ça dans le sens
que si la modernité
est l'émancipation des femmes
et l'admission des femmes
au droit de cité,
comme dirait Condorcet,
ou la présence des femmes
dans des situations
professionnelles,
des interactions professionnelles,
où vous êtes là "en tant que",
en tant que prof,
journaliste, ouvrière,
secrétaire,
ou même cheffe,
vous êtes là "en tant que",
femme politique,
eh bien ce n'est pas le moment,
ce n'est pas la situation
dans laquelle
vous acceptez avec plaisir
un compliment sur votre coiffure
ou un compliment
sur vos seins.
C'est justement...
-Essayez de terminer votre propos.
-Oui. Si, justement, par modernité,
on entend la présence des femmes
dans l'espace social
et dans l'espace du pouvoir,
alors effectivement,
il faut compartimenter,
il faut séparer.
Donc le même compliment
dont on n'a pas envie
en tant que femme
dans une situation
professionnelle,
ce même compliment,
eh bien on en est très heureuse
au lit ou dans un dîner
en tête à tête,
puisque le romantisme revient aussi.
-Merci.
Philippe Brenot, je crois
que vous voulez intervenir.
-A la fois, je suis d'accord
avec ce que vient de dire
Giulia Sassi, pardon...
-Sissa.
Je suis désolé, Giulia.
Que la sexualité des jeunes
ait changé depuis,
pas fondamentalement,
mais que ça ait transformé
la société,
que ça va transformer
les consciences,
formidable, formidablement.
Ce que nous essayons de faire,
tous les gens
qui s'occupent de sexualité,
quels qu'ils soient,
depuis 40 ans, on n'arrivait pas
à le faire, à faire comprendre...
Je me souviens avoir écrit
en 2008
un livre qui s'appelait
"Les violences ordinaires des hommes
envers les femmes".
La plupart des gens me disaient :
"Tu crois pas que c'est l'inverse ?"
Maintenant, les hashtags
vont avoir permis
une prise de conscience.
Le hashtag "inceste"
permet de comprendre des choses
que nous n'arrivions pas à dire.
Après, une petite pondération
par rapport à des choses
qui ont pu être dites avant.
Le problème des études,
et je ne sais pas,
celle dont vous parliez,
quelle est-elle.
Moi, je crois
qu'il n'y en a pas beaucoup,
d'études sur la sexualité.
Il y a beaucoup de sondages
faits par des journaux.
Il y a des études
qui sont idéologiques,
et notamment parce que...
En France,
il y a trois études.
-Essayez d'être pas trop long
parce qu'il nous reste peu de temps.
-D'accord.
Il y a trois études.
La dernière, c'est celle
de Michel Bozon et de...
-Nathalie Bajos.
-...et de Nathalie Bajos.
Il va y en avoir une autre,
mais elles ne montrent pas
tout un tas de choses
qui sont soutenues
souvent par des assoces
et par nous-mêmes pour arriver
à arrêter la discrimination,
mais on voit
des pourcentages hallucinants
dans des travaux qui ne sont pas
des études scientifiques.
Donc il faut être prudent.
Dernier point,
sur la baisse de sexualité
des jeunes.
Il y a une espèce de méta-analyse
qui a été faite
il y a trois ou quatre ans
aux Etats-Unis.
Je me demande même
si elle a pas été téléguidée
par des milieux conservateurs...
-Oui, mais là,
il s'agit pas des Etats-Unis,
c'est un sondage français.
-Nous, on ne voit pas ça,
dans les gens que nous voyons.
-Christine Vahdat,
vous vouliez intervenir.
-Je voulais rebondir
sur ce que disait Mme Sissa.
Je suis tout à fait d'accord
avec elle.
Tout dépend du contexte.
Effectivement qu'on aime
qu'on nous dise qu'on est belle,
mais ça ne me viendrait pas
à l'idée,
dans une réunion, de vous dire :
"Oh, que vous êtes beau !
"Vous êtes magnifique,
aujourd'hui !"
-Peut-être que ça plairait.
-Non mais en l'occurrence,
ça vous est jamais arrivé.
Or, à nous, ça nous est arrivé
de nous retrouver
dans des situations
où on était là,
où on avait le sentiment
d'être totalement
dans une égalité parfaite
avec les autres intervenants,
avec les autres participants,
et ça, ça revient tout le temps.
J'ai des patientes
qui sont
dans des conseils
d'administration
qui me disent
que c'est systématique
qu'elles aient comme ça
un pseudo-compliment
qui est totalement déplacé.
Elles le vivent
comme totalement déplacé
alors qu'elles sont
absolument ravies d'être désirées
dès qu'elles ont terminé
leur réunion.
Je pense que là-dessus,
MeToo est sûrement pas mal,
et je ne rejoins pas
celles que vous avez citées
qui ont crié à la catastrophe.
Il faut pas tomber dans les excès,
mais c'est vrai
qu'il y a
à remettre du contexte
dans le compliment
que l'on fait aux femmes.
Toutes les femmes que je vois
acceptent
tous les compliments des hommes,
à condition
qu'ils soient faits
au moment où...
C'est l'histoire
du consentement aussi.
Il y a un moment donné
où c'est la place
à la séduction,
aux compliments, etc.,
et puis il y a les moments
où ce n'est pas la place,
et c'est le discours
de celle qui le prononce
ou des propos qu'elle tient
qui doit être pris en compte
au-delà de son aspect physique.
-Merci. Alain Vanier,
une question qui fâche.
-Ah.
-Oui. J'aimerais bien que...
Je vous interroge là-dessus
parce que vous avez dirigé Bonneuil,
un centre d'adolescents
qui s'occupait
de psychopédagogie,
en tout cas aidait des adolescents
à se réinsérer
dans la société.
Aujourd'hui, on laisse...
Vous avez parlé de solitude,
mais on voit aussi
des bandes de garçons
et des filles,
et il y a une séparation.
Est-ce que vous considérez
que des garçons
qui n'ont pas de relations sexuelles
ou qui ne vont pas
avec des filles
sont plus violents ?
-Alors...
-Autrement dit,
c'est un sujet de délinquance.
-Oui, oui...
Je précise que Bonneuil,
c'est un hôpital de jour
qui accueillait des enfants
parfois très jeunes
jusqu'à des adolescents.
C'était un lieu
dit "d'antipsychiatrie",
c'était comme cela
quand Maud Mannoni l'a fondé.
Je ne l'ai pas dirigé,
j'y ai travaillé.
Mais...
Les bandes de garçons
ont toujours existé.
Les bandes de filles,
c'était moins fréquent,
mais le lien avec les copines,
c'était très important,
et il y avait,
effectivement,
une ségrégation sexuelle.
Je rappelle quand même que...
Je suis certainement
l'un des plus âgés ici.
Les écoles n'étaient pas mixtes,
il y a pas si longtemps que ça,
il y a une cinquantaine d'années.
-Oui, mais est-ce que
le féminin est un facteur
de pacification des instincts ?
C'est-à-dire rester entre hommes,
en quelque sorte,
et notamment
chez les bandes de jeunes,
est-ce que ça sécrète pas
de la délinquance ?
On dit que...
la mixité apporterait
plus d'humanité.
-De toute façon,
on ne peut qu'être d'accord
avec l'idée que ça apporterait
plus d'humanité,
mais je ne crois pas
que les bandes de garçons
suscitent automatiquement
de la délinquance.
Tout dépend
comment s'organisent ces bandes,
leur lieu,
les conditions sociales...
Elles ont toujours existé.
Moi qui suis certainement
le plus âgé ici,
ma jeunesse,
c'était les blousons noirs,
mais il y avait aussi
des bandes de garçons
qui allaient jouer au bowling,
qui se retrouvaient
pour faire de la musique, etc.
Je suis pas convaincu
que ce soit cela,
que la ségrégation des sexes
provoque nécessairement
plus de violence.
Non, je crois pas.
-Giulia, comment ça se passe...
Oui, je vous en prie.
-D'autant que je ne suis pas sûr,
on en parlait tout à l'heure,
qu'il y ait une augmentation
de la violence des jeunes.
Elle est plus spectaculaire,
elle est mise en avant
par les médias,
mais je ne suis pas sûr
qu'elle ait augmenté
par rapport à il y a
un demi-siècle.
-Oui, Giulia Sissa,
vous pensez quoi
de cette violence masculine
qui pourrait être tempérée
par un humanisme féminin ?
-J'aimerais bien penser
qu'il y a des traits
même construits, bien sûr,
construits culturellement
de la manière féminine des femmes
d'être au monde
qui sont partageables
de manière heureuse
dans le monde,
c'est-à-dire...
le soin, le souci,
l'empathie, tout ça.
C'est construit, je ne dis pas
que c'est naturel,
mais c'est bon.
Donc ce serait bien
qu'on partage
un peu tout ça.
Ceci dit, vous me posez une question
sur laquelle je ne peux pas
vous répondre
en tant que chercheuse
qui aurait travaillé
sur les bancs
de gangs, de délinquants.
Mais peut-être,
une question qui se pose beaucoup
aux Etats-Unis est pertinente, ici,
c'est la discussion
sur les écoles mixtes
ou seulement pour filles,
ou seulement pour garçons.
Est-ce qu'une éducation séparée,
n'est-ce pas,
où les genres sont séparés,
fait du bien ?
Est-ce que...
justement, en enlevant
la dimension de la sexualité
entre filles et garçons,
on enlève une distraction ?
Les avis divergent,
et, à la fois,
au sujet du bénéfice
que filles tireraient
de cette situation où il n'y a pas
de garçons, mais aussi
pour les garçons. L'idée
qu'il y ait une éducation masculine
qui soit vraiment
en instance consciente
de ce qu'il faut faire
pour transformer
le mâle humain
en un gentleman,
en un sens,
et donc que ce corps
vécu au masculin apprenne
à bien se conduire,
apprenne à ne pas être violent,
à ne pas s'imposer,
à ne pas...
perdre le contrôle,
justement, irrationnellement,
de son potentiel de force,
et donc...
-Merci.
*-Il y a une réflexion
sur tout ça.
-Merci, Giulia.
Bruno Falissard, sur ce point,
le féminin, le masculin,
aujourd'hui,
dans sa conjugaison,
on sait que ça aide
à amoindrir la délinquance.
-Non, je pense pas du tout.
-Pas du tout ?
-Je pense pas du tout.
Je pense que c'est un mythe.
Vraiment, le mythe
de la prédation sexuelle,
le mythe de la testostérone...
La testostérone est une hormone
qui a un effet,
mais c'est complètement
mythologisé.
Le mythe de la compétition
entre mâles pour la femelle,
qui existe chez les mammifères,
mais qui est
du registre du symbolique,
essentiellement, avec les humains.
C'est bien plus compliqué.
Après,
la séparation
des genres au collège,
c'est une vraie question.
Euh... Franchement,
moi, je ne vois pas
comment ça pourrait être
pertinent...
Du moins, sur le terme.
Je pense que les humains
sont faits pour être ensemble,
et que les humains divers,
peu importe
la diversité, ont besoin
d'être ensemble pour apprendre
à vivre ensemble,
que ce soit des hommes,
des femmes, des personnes
avec des handicaps, ou pas,
et voilà.
Pour moi, c'est vraiment
une évidence clinique.
Alors après,
peut-être que ça peut aider
à faire passer un pas,
mais pas plus que ça.
-Bon, on arrive au terme
de cette émission
et je vais vous poser
une question.
Chacun pourra donner
son mot de conclusion là-dessus.
On est dans une société
de consommation,
société du spectacle,
avec toutes ses qualités
ou ses défauts : malbouffe,
drogue, alcool, etc.,
mais aussi injonction
à la jouissance,
à la performance,
au porno, au viol, etc.
Vous connaissez tout ça.
Est-ce que vous pensez
que l'accomplissement
de l'intime
va continuer
à trouver sa place
ou, finalement,
on va vers un ersatz,
en quelque sorte,
d'amour
et de sexualité ?
Alors, brièvement,
chacun son point de vue.
Alain Vanier ?
-Je pense qu'il y a quand même,
malgré la surexposition,
la transparence d'aujourd'hui,
qui est une transparence
parfois mal vécue.
Je pense quand même
que la plupart des personnes,
en tout cas,
celles que je reçois,
finissent par construire
un espace intime
à leur manière,
mais peut-être aussi avec...
en assumant
plus facilement la diversité
ou la singularité des constructions
qu'à l'époque
où, au fond,
il y avait un ordre
plus uniformément défini.
-Christine Vahdat,
sur ce mot de ponctuation, là ?
*-Oui,
je suis, moi aussi,
une éternel "optimisme",
"optimiste",
et je pense qu'on arrive
vers des relations
plus égalitaires, plus...
Il n'y a qu'à voir les chiffres
sur l'âge du premier rapport,
qui est maintenant le même
pour les filles et les garçons.
C'est un peu
caricatural et simpliste,
mais j'ai l'impression que,
au contraire, on va vers du positif
dans les échanges
entre les relations,
malgré les déviances
que vous avez citées
dans votre question
sur la société de consommation
et tous ces délires, voilà.
Donc je suis très optimiste
sur les relations garçons-filles,
et sur ces ados,
en insistant sur le consentement
qui a été repris,
et je l'en remercie,
par Bruno Falissard,
parce que ça me paraît
la question clé
de la sexualité des adolescents.
-Merci.
Monsieur Brenot ?
-Moi je serais optimiste
avec cette marge de recul
vis-à-vis d'énormément
de facteurs qui se sont passés.
Il y a une révolution du numérique,
vous le disiez.
C'était en 2000,
c'était il y a 23 ans.
Il y a les hashtags.
C'était il y a 5 ou 6 ans.
Maintenant, c'est incroyable,
ce qui s'est passé comme choses.
Beaucoup de choses
sont allées très vite.
Quand on regarde les études
sur les ados, ils sont
de plus en plus critiques.
Ils savent très bien,
même par rapport au porno :
c'est pas la vraie sexualité.
D'ici une dizaine d'années,
des choses vont s'appesantir :
c'est allé très vite et tant mieux.
C'est des changements
qu'on n'arrivait pas
à faire.
-Ou.
Giulia Sissa,
vous pensez que l'intime
n'est pas en danger.
*-Non,
parce que je fais confiance
aux jeunes.
Je pense que tout ce dont on parle,
c'est un défi.
C'est un défi à l'esprit critique.
C'est un défi à la capacité
de décider, de choisir,
de faire des expériences,
mais ce que je vois
quand je parle à des jeunes
à qui je pose
cette question :
"Est-ce que vous pensez
être analphabètes ?"
-On a peu de temps,
Giulia. Essayez
d'être concise.
*-Je leur fais confiance.
Je pense qu'il y a
de nouvelles éthiques de l'intime
qui émergent
et je suis plutôt curieuse
de ce que je devrais apprendre de...
-Merci,
Giulia Sissa. Bruno Falissard,
sur cette même question,
mais par rapport
à ce qu'a dit
Christine Vahdat,
des relations plus égalitaires.
Je vous rappelle
simplement
que Michelle Perrot,
qui était une écrivaine
très connue
en France et qui s'intéresse
à ces questions de société,
disait qu'il faut
garder le cap
de l'universel pour réaliser
l'égalité.
Est-ce qu'aujourd'hui,
on ne fait pas passer
l'égalité avant l'universel ?
C'est une grosse question,
mais c'est pour avoir
votre avis.
Est-ce que...
-D'abord, dans le domaine
de la sexualité et du couple,
"l'universel", je ne sais pas
ce que c'est, par contre,
ce que je constate, c'est que vivre
à deux proches l'un de l'autre
pendant de nombreuses années,
c'est une valeur
qui est encore
très forte chez les jeunes,
et c'est très impressionnant
de voir
comment vouloir être à côté
de quelqu'un,
lui tenir la main
ou regarder la télé
ensemble,
ou Netflix, etc.,
c'est quelque chose
de très fort encore.
-OK.
Bien, écoutez,
le temps imparti
est écoulé.
Il me reste à vous présenter
une brève bibliographie,
un livre
de Magali Croset-Calisto,
"La révolution du No Sex".
Magali Croset-Calisto explique,
par contre, justement,
ce que ce dont on a parlé,
c'est-à-dire l'affaiblissement
des relations sexuelles
en partie contesté
par vous-même,
mais elle le montre.
Alors, Giulia Sissa,
vous avez publié
"Le pouvoir des femmes"
chez Odile Jacob.
Bon, c'est évident.
En un mot, en un mot !
Parce qu'on a peu de temps.
Il se raffermit
ou il diminue ?
En un mot.
*-On avance.
On avance,
on avance.
-Vous avancez.
*-Oui, on avance.
Nous avançons
toutes et tous ensemble.
Ce féminisme est
un grand cadeau à l'humanité.
-Merci de cet optimisme.
Bruno Falissard,
vous avez publié
"Soigner la souffrance
psychique des enfants".
Elle grandit, aujourd'hui,
dans cette société de consommation ?
-Il y a des choses qui vont mieux :
moins de tentatives de suicide
et de suicides chez les adolescents
au 21e siècle.
Par certains aspects,
ça va moins bien :
il y a plus d'états dépressifs.
Il y a du bien et du moins bien.
-Philippe Brenot,
"Pourquoi c'est
si compliqué l'amour,
Donc, bon, c'est toujours
une question complexe ?
-Oui, dans "Pourquoi
c'est compliqué l'amour",
à travers beaucoup d'expériences
et de choses qu'on sait,
il y a de grandes différences
entre les hommes et les femmes
qu'on ne veut pas accepter
parce qu'on voudrait
qu'il y ait une égalité.
Idéologiquement, pourquoi pas,
mais dans la réalité,
nous devons faire
avec des stéréotypes,
et je crois qu'on est mieux
si on accepte
les différences qu'en les niant.
-Merci.
Alain Vanier,
Vous êtes un biographe de Lacan.
Vous préparez un livre, là,
actuellement ?
-Euh, oui,
un livre sur la question
des relations précoces
des tout petits enfants,
à partir de deux expériences :
celle d'avoir travaillé
pendant tout un temps
avec des mères psychotiques
et leur bébé,
avec une variante très étonnante
de ces relations
très précoces,
et puis avec mon épouse
qui, elle, a travaillé
dans des services
tels que...
-Catherine Vanier.
-On essaye de faire
quelque chose
de la leçon qu'on a tirée
de ces expériences.
-Merci. Alors,
il me reste
à vous remercier,
à remercier Giulia Sissa,
de Los Angeles,
Christine Vahdat,
de sa belle campagne...
Vous êtes où,
Christine Vahdat ?
*-Normandie,
à côté de Beaumont-en-Auge.
-La belle Normandie.
Merci, messieurs,
d'avoir participé.
Merci à l'équipe de LCP
qui réalise cette émission.
Et avant de vous quitter,
je voudrais vous soumettre
cette pensée
de Michel Houellebecq :
"Il y a la sexualité
des gens qui s'aiment
"et la sexualité
des gens qui ne s'aiment pas".
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA